welcome back what is this this is the
cover your job very slow guys dead now
yeah
big dick no turn it off yeah yeah season
welcome back it's Jim Norton and Sam
Roberts zac amico is here Zach whoa
tom pappas here and we have Natalia
coming in from w e Nattie Neidhart also
from total divas and Smackdown and
Survivor Series and she's a busy woman I
can't believe that you're here I mean I
knew you were booked obviously yeah like
I was watching a Smackdown last night
and like you're on the after show and
everything and for you you just made the
trip just leave directly from SmackDown
and come right to New York yet by in a
car that was ready to pick me up and I
kept the driver waiting I was having a
coaching session with Alexa and Carmel
and Locker ah
were they coaching on I was just talking
him through you know the fact that we
know you coaching them sorry well I was
I was talking to them about you know
that we have a little nickname we call
ourselves three disgruntled blondes and
no but it was yeah we I came in last
night and um when I found out that I was
gonna speak to you I was like this is
great this is the highlight of my
morning no one has ever said that before
thank you Jim wakes up and feels that
way every morning I want you to know
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah he's very happy
about it um there's a big week for you
yeah this is huge
um obviously tonight total divas season
six
premiering on e 8:00 p.m. and it's cool
because I mean I never thought we would
get to six seasons when I started the
show I was like do a my a train wreck
since I was picked into a reality show
and I guess I am slightly less like
train wreck but we started the first
season and then all of a sudden we in
March will be filming for almost four
years so it's just crazy because it's
also crazy they cram six seasons into
four years yeah just like we're doing
more we're doing more we're doing more
the show has done so well and it's like
you every single season we always say to
ourselves like what else can we do like
what's it about the show
I haven't seen it it's just about our
lives in and out of WWE but life evolved
so that's how the show gets content
because you really we have these really
unique lives we're on the road 280 plus
days a year and you know a lot of us are
with men that are involved in the
industry and it's the first time WWE has
ever let any cameras backstage to film
the behind the scenes stuff because I
don't even let family like I do not let
my own family come backstage unless they
are booked by mr. McMahon himself right
to be on the show because it's a very
private world if people are discussing
you know storylines nobody is allowed
back there but this is the first time
that they let cameras back there to film
our lives behind the scenes and just so
much stuff has happened through over the
last four years and people just find the
show fascinating because you look at
other reality shows just nobody has the
jobs that we have when you go to work in
your job description is body-slamming
someone it doesn't get any better than
that
well yeah and I mean the people who get
involved in wrestling or somewhat crazy
people yes generally the show really
hooked me when I found out r-truth was
scared of cats that was the craziest
thing ever true literally I mean I spent
$85 at Whole Foods on like three steaks
I didn't realize I was spending that
until I got to the counter and truth'
literally put his foot into the steaks
on the top of my counter because he
couldn't handle my cats he jumped on my
counter as if he was Roman reigns
jumping over a barrier again ring it
robbed you like cats he's afraid of that
he said he was attacked by a herd and I
never realized how afraid he was of cats
until that day that he came to my house
and then he just like lost it I had to
literally spend an hour in my driveway
negotiating I like to this guy is like
Jim doesn't know but he's a giant black
dude who's like a rapper and a wrestler
who you wouldn't think would be afraid
of much yeah he's you know he's an
awesome one of my best friends but he
was so scared of the cats and of course
at the time we had Cesaro over and Big E
and Kofi and Fandango and everybody was
just teasing truth about his fear of
cats and he got
really sensitive about it how tall is it
but maybe 6-1 6-2 is bigger yes very big
guy he's very easy it isn't weird how
big guy you'd be scared something so
small just step on the [ __ ] thing
that's like an elephant no villanova my
cats are very special cats especially to
pause to pause as is on t-shirt and
Instagram the other way sending his own
chocolate bar is that right yes Wow
yeah yeah super daddy I think went into
business for herself a little bit went
on smackdowns after show the other week
and just started promoting her Instagram
of her cat why two paws why do you call
now well brie bella actually named two
paws we were discussing names and I'm a
huge fan of Tupac um I'm obsessed a
Tupac and I'm not really obsessed with
rap I just love Tupac and Biggie is
another cat biggie is one of the yeah
the wrestler yeah did you said biggie
right you said big you say he is a
wrestler that my sister Jenny is
infatuated with I'll get into that but
it'll you'll see that on season 6 and
totally but she's in love with him she's
obsessed with him and it wasn't supposed
to be that way he was just coming over
to hang out and he's this I mean when
you see when you see Big E he's very
built in the front stacked in the back
yeah he he he's got a bit of a bubble
pop but biggie is like like his is his
wrestling gimmick you know Jim as he
wears those like tiny trunks and he
gyrates his hips and non-stop my sister
met him and she just fell in love she's
like I love biggie so every time I see
biggie I have to give him this bear hug
and tell him I watch my sister loves
them and um but Brie Bella named two
paws she named she named the cat and
he's been the cat's been doing so
incredible like his Instagram following
is going through the roof you're just
blown away by success so proud of it you
are so proud of him as if as if he's
responsible for all that great success
he doesn't even know he's on Instagram
he just likes to cover his own [ __ ] with
something I'm trying to get Shane
McMahon to follow him but I think Shane
likes cats I hope he does way doesn't
like yours he's not following him right
I'm disappointed that you guys are
following neither is on Daniel Bryan but
we'll get there I think baby steps we're
not gonna get there today but we might
get there tomorrow
Sammy I'm not really into the
wrestling's much now because I've got
kids and all that stuff but is this a
good
for wrestling it's is this like a golden
era it's getting very good again it's a
bit of a dip and it's starting to get
especially for the women it's been
incredible yeah women just headline
their first pay-per-view which is like a
huge deal - yeah and a headline well and
who do you think the audience is for
those if men or women it is - men now
it's they're the athletic is incredible
for the first time especially in America
right like male wrestling fans are
watching women wrestle and just watching
like they're watching wrestling who is
the who is the headline with Ric Flair's
daughter Charlotte and sasha banks both
incredible sasha banks i know who she
understood it was so cool though like
seeing them get that moment because it's
it really shows like WWE is embracing
women more than they ever have and we're
showing that you know I still believe
firmly as much as we I don't men and
women are so different and obviously but
like when I started get and I've talked
a lot with Charlotte about this because
when I first met Charlotte she pulled me
aside she was practically in tears and
she talked to me because she understood
like I come from you know big family
just like you know her dad is she comes
from that lineage and she's like I just
don't feel like I'm good enough I'm
pretty enough I'm strong enough I'm I'm
I don't feel like I fit in and I said I
felt the same way when I started in
wrestling because I always felt like I
was gonna have this stigma attached to
me coming from this line of like the
Hart family royalty yeah wrestling
royalty when you have Stu Hart as your
grandfather and Bret and Owen Hart and
the British bulldogs as your uncle and
your dad as Jim Neidhart and your you
know it's like how am I going to fill
those shoes and I told Charlotte I said
I went through all the same stuff and it
was so cool to be able to share my
experience of like feeling the same way
that I didn't remember my first trip to
Japan
and I was so terrified I actually like
almost forgot how to wrestle and I I was
just like how am I gonna how am I gonna
follow in Bret Hart's footsteps but you
realize no you don't want to follow in
their footsteps so I told Charlotte I'm
like you can pay homage to your dad but
you are not your dad you are blazing
your own trail do something different
the women are so different than the men
and I think you know that's the thing
what they're they're Hell in a Cell man
yes it was a historical monumental
moment for a lot of different reasons
but we're still so different and that's
what makes us unique that's what makes
us special that's what makes people tune
in and those girls actually were super
respectful to me a few weeks ago we were
talking and both Sasha and Charlotte
kind of came forward and they were like
if it wasn't for you know women like you
nati helping kind of you know open up
that door even though it took it took a
long time for us to get here we might
not have gotten here if we didn't all
just keep pressing do you think the
interestingly web because women people
wouldn't have been involved in wresting
but you get like Ronda Rousey and Misha
fighting in UFC and then you see how
popular it is in combat sports so it's
like it's just natural people want to
say you're 100 percent right I think
Ronda Rousey totally helped open that
door for us and I think the success of
it look at the Olympics this year yeah
who are the stars in my opinion I mean
I'm biased but who are the stars of the
Olympics is Ryan Lochte Ohno gas station
security guard u.s. women's gymnastics
team and it's like these girls just
shined so much and they were such
positive like forces with each other and
so you know we were talking earlier Samm
about um the two different brands now we
have raw we have smackdown each having
their own championship and it's just so
refreshing to see like WWE embracing
multiple women's storylines we were
overseas there was two different yeah
matches on the tour yeah you know girls
matches and it's it's amazing too that
you've kind of hung in there as long as
you've hung in there because it must
have been frustrating at first cuz when
they first brought Nattie into WWE it
wasn't this thing where people actually
appreciated women's wrestling it was a
bunch of models and a bunch of like
Playboy chicks and then also Nattie who
could actually wrestle right and so she
stuck out like a sore thumb actually
trying to have matches with a lot of
women some of whom weren't even
coordinated enough to walk to get into
the ring right I mean it's funny you
bring that up because like I leta
actually said this a while ago and I
thought it was really like fitting she
said the revolution
um the revolution was waiting you know
for there was girls that were ready for
the revolution when the revolution
wasn't ready for them and I feel like I
came to
w/e in a really weird time I had a hard
time getting hired it took me five years
to get hired I kept getting rejected
because the I just wasn't what they
liked that I wasn't I wasn't
that's not what they were doing at the
time what you have to do to get hired
you have to like audition well you have
to send you know tapes and and pictures
and I didn't really know what to do yeah
I didn't want to go through my family I
didn't want to have my uncle Brett make
a phone call or you know I wanted to do
it on my own and I just kept getting
rejected because at the time it was just
a different era but I was just focused
on wrestling plus I was I was a little
heavier so I think I was wrestling in
Japan and just carving up so at the time
it was more going hard on the noodles
going hard on the noodle embarrassing
bettered again sashimi then sushi that's
what I say but I'm so good-natured it's
so cool that I can be a part of it now
and I have hung in there because it's
been so frustrating cuz all my forte was
wrestling and that's what I love is
wrestling and I just never fit in with
being a model or doing the did you know
the at the time they had diva dance offs
or you know different kind of like that
was just where they were at the time but
for me I will always love the wrestling
so now it's like this focus on wrestling
and I just love it and it's so cool
coming back after a match and having mr.
McMahon or Triple H and or Stephanie or
just the you know
our bosses be like so proud of us for
going in the ring and doing what you
love what did you do before that before
you wrestled I wrestled oh you are you
always wrestling yeah I was born and
raised in this big crazy wrestling
family my grandfather had a wrestling
ring in our yard and we would put on
shows we actually ran her own wrestling
promotion called the kids wrestling
association yeah and so my uncle Owen
would teach like my husband and my
cousins how to do back flips in the ring
and like we would put on our own shows
every single Sunday we would have a show
and I was a bell ringer I was a manager
I was a commentator I was part of a
battle royal I mean I did okay I've
always been a wrestling family see that
was the only job you ever had I also
sold vacuums for a week that sucked ha
ha I'm being cute oh it did please
everybody tell daddy you don't have to
be polite to Jim if you don't want
as such an odd job to have for a week I
had it for a week and I was the fallback
plan I was 17 when I had the job and it
was like basically was selling Kirby
vacuums and um I don't know how I got
talked into doing it but the Commission
was really high if you could sell this
$3,000 vacuum you got like $1,000
Commission the only person that bought a
vacuum for me after I cleaned their
entire house showing them how the stupid
vacuum worked was my grandfather out of
pity so everybody else you would just
clean their house they'd be like oh yeah
no not for me but thank you oh yeah
clean their entire house right and then
get back into my Dodge Neon bursting
into tears going to 7-eleven getting a
Slurpee to refresh but but yeah then I
was like you know what I think I need to
get the dungeon and train what did you
want to separate really what they were
doing like you're like I'm gonna go out
and kind of do my own thing
you have vacuum cleaners that's my
passion yeah an arresting person this is
an odd thing to get into I I was
approached about hosting this kids
wrestling show called merits at the time
Eric Bischoff was running it Mauro
Ranallo was a part of it and as a
commentator and all my cousins were
involved in it they wanted me to host
the show they were like you be cool to
host it and how long ago was this this
was in 2000 okay this is in 2000 Mauro
Ranallo who she just mentioned like this
year got hired by WWE to be a
commentator that's how long it's stuff
like this take like you just stay in the
game doing commentary for kids wrestling
show whatever you wherever you can get
work until Salalah gross battle you see
that disgust ik with it moral well you
got to stick with it you can't it's like
you can't I'm telling you it takes years
for people to nobodies an overnight
sensation here nobody yeah it takes
years to get there more was one of the
best commentators in the world right but
he started when he was a teenager
because he just was passionate about
wrestling not just WWE but like my
family is just passionate about
wrestling and we obviously loved WWE but
like wrestling's just in our I can't
remember a day that we didn't talk about
it you know that we didn't like we had
the dungeon we had a ring in our yard I
was a part of it my whole life so it's
just it's a really cool world it's
especially when you go anywhere and just
size people up and go bodyslam you so
when they put together the team so
survive
this weekend it's on w/e Network right
yes and it's they said only $9.99 a
month ninety-nine a month
we9 what that's it Tom what's a Mahalo
you can come with a poster do you get a
poster I'll make you one
yeah I'll print something out for you
you get every match right all the paper
views yeah everything and the archive
like I'm saying everything they've done
to make me feel foolish Jim used to make
fun of me because before the WWE Network
I literally at a DVD recorder and I
would DVR every TV show and then I would
run the DVR back and record literally
every row every smackdown everything
onto DVDs and I don't have these binders
and it would take forever and then they
make this announcement like hey the
whole archives gonna be here and you're
like it's like I have your whole
existence has been [ __ ] well it's funny
the network is kind of addicting and
it's like they always tell you know they
always when especially when the network
was first coming out they were always
like ok guys pump it up but the thing is
is that it so many of us that work in
the company are fans um like TJ my you
know my husband and I were just like
obsessed fans on top of being you know a
part of the company we love wrestling so
when the network came we were just like
I remember showing Bret how to like Bret
Hart you know my uncle he he he was like
what is this and he was like I can watch
these matches back and all of a sudden
he got hooked on the network and and
then he was at takeover and Pat
Patterson and him were like bigger like
looking at the network watching all
these old matches and we were actually
like Bret we're getting ready to go on
stage like you got to stop watching the
network yeah but we weren't even like
telling anybody about this we just got
the network's addicting and it is it
really is very cheap I think the first
month is free first month's free and its
telecom I'm not kidding
especially if you're a fan of the old
it's impossible to find a lot of that
stuff did you know me Bob Backlund he
walks around the network I imagine
enough yeah quite a it's really cool Jim
loves old school Bob Backlund oh yeah I
was a Superfly fan Bob is weird though
Bob is very odd oh yeah yeah see him he
just goes into these wild Rams yeah he's
a crazy guy right
he is Jim likes the subdued promos that
he used to do like the all-american well
Vince yeah that's the event I got to get
out there and do the best I can
and they're like oh my god see funny guy
um but so Survivor Series this weekend
they've separated the rosters you know
like Raw and SmackDown uh-huh two
totally separate rosters oh that's right
and they're taking all the women on Raw
and they're gonna face all the women on
Smackdown five on five what's the
difference different people just
different rosters yeah there's no
together wrestling's the same though I
mean it's like the the you know baseball
has their - Aaron come finish the
division no attempt darker League
National League whatever that is
like I'm watching the network I don't
care about baseball you know yeah that's
boring um but the network start out the
network the the roster is like we have
raw we have Smackdown so there there
really is a different feel for both
shows like the just different flavors of
ice cream I think um I'm biased I like
Smackdown better I think it's just
easier to follow because it's two hours
and it's just like keeping you know
going but uh well I use a cool jib shot
instead of a steady shot
yeah what's different and um that's the
same as well film - three hour show
though so it's like it's you get a see
you know a little bit you get a little
bit more on Raw because it's a little
bit longer but then we have talking
smack after smack down which everybody
you know I sit up after show who hosts
that Daniel Bryan and Renee young do you
want that job do it no tonight honestly
Daniel Bryan Renee young are incredible
if anybody who is even slightly lousy
yeah I'd be you know running them into
the ground and saying I should be doing
it right but they're really realize the
show every every week so I ask you what
mostly like I looked at Ric Flair's
daughter her picture and the most women
in wrestling just date wrestlers well
what happens is we're on the road like
280 plus days a year and you're just
around everybody so much that it's like
I said to one of the girls I was like
it's weird getting on flights with other
people like on without me because when
we were on tour we were on tour for two
weeks and we would have these charters
that would only be us and so when you go
to work and your coworkers are Brock
Lesnar Randy Orton the Big Show I mean
all these like you know your those are
your coworkers they're gonna sleep with
them know yours well that jumped ahead
Ketel but it's just like we have such a
unique group of people that we work with
it it's like hard sometimes being around
people that aren't like if you're in a
wrestling van I don't know if I can have
a talk with you
right um granted you know we've gotten
into the total divas market now wherever
it's like you go on a plane and
somebody's like Nattie oh my gosh my
husband's not romantic either you're
like oh let me watch totally yeah that's
gotta be a female audience right but for
the Divas huge female audio and that's
the cool thing is that when we started
total divas it brings over this
different demographic of women that had
never ever watch WWE that of a sudden go
oh we want to like all of a sudden see
what you guys are doing yeah and there's
so many women now let's say we never
watch WWE until total divas now we love
it our kids love it
we're we're so into the show which is
good because that was kind of the whole
point of doing the show is bringing over
this different audience but a lot of us
do date and are married to wrestlers
about Charlotte um Charlotte is single
as far as I know but my comedians just
come and manager how old is ask Jimmy is
at least 30 and Jimmy she's one of my
favorite people that I've ever wrestled
I have this magical chemistry with
Charlotte and I just from the moment
that I first met her and just I love
that I love that she was so open about
like I don't feel like I'm good enough
and that's what WWE I feel like that's
one of the most wonderful parts of our
job is like really growing into your
role and believing in yourself and
finding confidence and being able to
help for me to be able to help Charlotte
find her confidence especially like in
that takeover match yeah yeah it was one
of my greatest accomplishments because
that's I feel like that's what this is
all about is paying it forward see like
why here's why she hears my Charlotte I
would be good together
because I would like I don't watch a
whole lot of wrestling's you know just
talk to about other stuff and she's like
wow this guy really likes me for me and
he's not trying to find out inside stuff
I should be bored by that I think she'd
be very bored she's much more athletic
than yeah my sister I do I go there you
work out I'll go on the elliptical
I got charlatan - oh my my my coach is
John Cena John Cena's coach John his
name is Rob McIntyre and he trains John
and Nikki and Cesaro and Sheamus and
rusev and all these different literally
the strongest wrestlers on television
and Beth rumex got me training with Rob
and so now I got Charlotte training with
Rob and Charlotte broke a record that I
had in the gym and I was like why is my
name off chalkboard what was the record
it was for front squad she broke it by
like six pounds and I'm just livid I'm
like what's your front squat record Jim
I don't do that I don't ever let them to
tell me how much they throw whatever is
whatever is available they throw on I do
it and I'm like come back for more when
you got it they just find stuff to put
on the bar yeah all the weights
available in a couple of purses I just
love it that's so impressive yeah Jim
sworn to burpees yeah who's your
favorite wrestlers uh Natalya yeah yeah
yeah I paid him what about I'm a big
Charlotte fan you are make sure I like
how tall is she she's about I think five
foot nine that's cool cuz I'm five seven
women like that tend to like a shorter
guy I don't think so I don't think
that's right she just said she hangs out
with Randy Orton in the Big Show and
Brock less exactly she's tired of those
guys oh she needs somebody different
boring another tall guy tall guy great
shape yawn let me go with the little guy
who hates himself
buddy cuz those are like those are just
like the like they're not they're not
normal people we know they're not but
like when you're just like getting on a
charter and you're like oh you're
walking past guys that are like seven
feet tall I mean even the great remember
the great khali
I remember the great khali he's one of
my good like we've become very good
friends over the years and like he's a
legit giant and he we haven't even we
would ride together I would we would
drive from like you know I was I was one
of his riding partners um with a certain
foot one yeah but one and he'd have
these long conversations with me about
like wrestling and like he was very nice
sweet like sensitive guy but he was
seven foot one so every time we go to a
gas station or something people will be
like like it was a good attraction yeah
like he couldn't do anything anywhere
you know we he would he was he was
really cool but yeah that's those are
like the people that we work with so I
don't know if I'm sure with my self
esteem ventures I got five Jimi's it's
like five it is like five Jimi's yeah
but super light that I have a different
point of view and I talk about different
stuff just should work work work right
you'd probably like hey this guy talks
about different stuff and he doesn't he
doesn't just use me for my wrestling
like a lot of guys would use her just to
get into matches and she would know that
I Jenny
they like her it's the whole thing well
you're very genuine and sincere and a
lot of women like that she would like
that yes you see Charlotte it at that
survivor she maybe you put in a Jim
Norton was asking about you word but I
can't make any promises out chef
indicating that she can't make any
promises that's fairness what you gonna
do she thought she can't make a promise
for a friend so my question that is
going to ask you about Survivor Series
was they made this five woman team from
Smackdown mmm-hmm you're not on the team
you're the your your storyline your the
coach is the story and I'll tell you as
soon as they announced that you were the
coach all I wanted and I don't even know
if you thought of this I said on my
podcast and everything all I wanted was
for you to be like a Tonya Harding
character just took out one of the
chicks so then you and you gotta know
what happened in training there was an
accident
I story find out that you had destroyed
this woman's chances so that you could
get ahead I was kind of blown away when
they were like we want you to be the
coach and I was like um I'm not gonna
brag but I am gonna brag I am one of the
best women wrestlers in the world yeah
and I'm sick of these little pipsqueaks
like carmella Alexis that's why they
wanted you to coach me to be good
tension so the tension is doing what's
up over no but if you want to be in that
position maybe you have a little tension
maybe that's good for two I'm like the
Bela Karolyi of coaches I'm like girls
we're gonna we are gonna win because of
me though yeah and you were bummed out
when you found out you weren't on the DL
because I was like this is like the
story of my life
like yeah like I look like smackdown
like okay you're separated from some of
the other women like now it's a and here
it is after all these years you know
I've put in my time with it like nine
years in and it's taught well you're
gonna be the coach what I know and
that's where you start to reach your
breaking point and that's where you have
to get a little Jim Neidhart on everyone
and say I'm gonna get hungry and forget
my manners yeah and um what was also
funny is that I had this whistle that I
um came out with on Smackdown last week
and I went to blow the whistle and it's
like it is legit the story of my life
the whistle didn't work and I was blown
it was a boy if I dealt with that I go
kneel for whistle blowing practice
remember when you blow that I always
worked it was like Nattie please
and the whistle didn't work I shove
Nicky really hard and she was like huh I
was like I'm sorry I was frustrated
yeah that's a setting yeah you got to
apologize setting it's gonna be cool
though Survivor Series will be awesome
it'll be I mean I'm excited too for um
Brock Lesnar and Goldberg cuz that we
gotten over a decade
Goldberg's coming back to wrestle Brock
Lesnar we should I mean it's good I
would hope it'll be good nobody seen
Brock Lesnar I mean Goldberg wrestle in
12 years it's gonna be I mean and we
know rock is seriously like he's just
untamed like he the guy even just
walking past him in a hallway he's scary
he is so scary because he's just his
presence is larger than life and you
could say what you want about you know
Pro Wrestling and and the legitimacy of
it or whatever but the last time Brock
Lesnar had a match it ended by him
driving his elbow into the dudes head
legit and resting him open really like
he does like this this whole idea of
like performance art or sports
entertainment like it kind of stops
right for Brock he doesn't it doesn't
know what UFC right and look the bottom
line was I didn't enjoy the Mark Hunt
fights I enjoy Mark Hunt but he beat a
guy who [ __ ] hits like a freight
train yeah and yeah he beat the mark on
yeah well he he just broke his system a
different breed of human really and he's
um he's always been like the funny thing
is he's just always been super
respectful and polite every time I've
seen him but he's just this presence
that's larger than life but you also not
he's not just athletic he's a polarizing
personality yeah and then you throw in
Paul Heyman who is in my opinion one of
the best talkers great like anytime Paul
Heyman's on TV I have to see what's
going on yeah um but but Brock is he's
got this polarizing personality like
Conor McGregor where you're just like I
want to see what he's going to do unless
I enjoy watching Conor because I'm like
every time Connor is on it it reminds me
very much of what we do because he's
just such a larger-than-life personality
he really is I mean did you watch the
last good fight over the weekend did the
Vince McMahon walk around the cage
absolutely not without walking 100% no
he was doing it on purpose but somebody
put a Wally walk to the Vince music and
he looks like Vince McMahon walking
around the cage well it's funny because
Connor calls it it he calls it the Billy
walk and I was saying why does he call
it the Billy walk and he's like it's the
billionaire
because I they're like mr. McMahon yeah
um but it's cool because I can tell that
Connor McGregor is a huge fan of WWE I
mean just the fact that he needed to
have his two belts shows you that it's
not just like a sport for he needs that
show yes at the end of the thing he
needs that moment where he's holding up
both titles
it's that showmanship that goes back to
the days of gorgeous George
yeah and then you see that you know you
saw that in Ric Flair and you saw that
in like all these you know amazing
iconic superstars for history that it's
a vault like Conor McGregor I mean he
probably doesn't even realize that he
has qualities at gorgeous George had
right so total divas is on tonight 8:00
p.m.
e uh total d what was because you kind
of opened up a lot on that show yeah um
maybe too much yeah you've done a lot of
stuff about the problems in your
relationship with it what was the
decision like when you decided that you
were going to talk about the fact that
your dad had struggles with substances
because your dad's in the evil Knight
heart and he's had you know he said
troubles with sub-races and they
addressed it on the show and the you
know him needing go to rehab and all all
that it was known before divas he yeah
yeah oh yeah big time you know what that
story it's funny because I've talked to
um I was talking to some of the upper
management WWE about it I said I'm so
happy that I did that story because I
was very hesitant about sharing that
story on total divas because I've always
just been super protective of my dad and
um you know and just because you know
that's what you do and in families you
protect the ones that you love but I
also felt like with WWE's help I was
able to get my dad help and that's part
of like I feel like in a lot of ways WWE
helped save my dad's life and I wanted
to be able to share that story with my
dad so many people across the world go
through issues and you know you realize
issues with drugs and alcohol it's a
disease and my dad was going through a
really hard time in his life WWE helped
save his life and I wanted to share this
story with the world so that people on
people could watch that episode and go
you know what I can relate to that I'm
not alone we got my dad the help that he
needed he feels so much better
and it was also about my dad finding his
confidence again because you go from
being a superstar that's
larger-than-life to all of a sudden you
know you get older my dad was involved
in so many different sports then he got
older and he didn't feel like he was
important and it's like no now he's now
he's under WWE legends contract and so
he got himself feeling better he um he
looks great he still drives me crazy
Lana by the way is a new cast member
that had a scene with my dad in this
upcoming season of total divas my dad
was trying to teach her out a shotput
and my dad is so funny because he's got
this innocence about him even though
he's the anvil he was trying to like
show her my dad used to be an olympic
shot-putter and down he's trying to show
her a shot but she ends up throwing the
shotput into the windshield of my car
awesome my dad looked at he's like gosh
do you believe she did that like any
like kind of got upset and I was like go
in the house now like I yelled at my dad
and I was the parent there and long as
he could crying and what's awesome that
he was a shot putter that it broke her
windshield the windshields funny right
yeah when she cried two for two crying
on my lawn like I was like Lana you're
literally I was reaching my breaking
point with her but my dad was such a
good sport and he's so funny on total
divas and like like I said it's that's
one my favorite things about being on
the show and I've talked to the Bella
Twins about that because you know they
have their spin-off total Bella's and
they said that one of the things they
love about doing that show and total
divas is that our family is going to be
a part of it like my dad gets to feel
important and he gets to feel like he is
you know somebody you know because it's
hard when you step out of the spotlight
and you know my dad now feels he just
feels excited to be a part of something
fun and we have these great family
moments and my dad's doing great it's
cool because people watch the show and
they go yeah I can I get that I went
through that or my sister went through
my dad went through it would be cool to
see Jimmy just all sudden walking in the
background of these scenes ladies
becomes part of the family slowly how
great we got Deena it's like one of the
joys a girl crying on a lawn jeez get
that guy here can't take out with a
hard-on out of the
I would love so much joining us if one
of the I'm just watching total divas and
one of the female wrestlers is like ah
this is my new boyfriend he's a comedian
and Jimmy's just it's just Norton she
wants a marrying Jim yeah I think you
see her hit me I stand up straight give
me the power singer and all Hofstra what
did you have in a BabyBjorn all the
other women are just talking behind her
back like I don't know what she's doing
dating him this day I make it easy I've
been good looking weird it's creepy
well uh we're out of time Nattie you are
the greatest oh thank you I love talking
to you me too I love talking to you